c'est une tendance qui se confirme au
200e jour du conflit l'armée ukrainienne
continuent de gagner du terrain au
nord-est près de rare qu'yves ou sa
contre offensive a pris de court les
soldats russes eux qui s'attendait
davantage à être attaqué sur le front
sud au petit fca donc mais aussi bas la
clia coupe inc et yum dont la prise a
été annoncée dimanche soir par le
président et lenski izon les
représailles russes n'ont pas tardé avec
selon kiev le bombardement du réseau
électrique de la ville des frappes
également constaté à pau croft plus au
sud
basé à washington l'institut pour
l'étude de la guerre là sur kiev a
repris en cinq jours plus de territoire
que les russes n'en n'ont conquis depuis
avril en tout plus de 3000 kilomètres
carrés serait revenue sous son contrôle
depuis début septembre
des pertes que le ministère russe de la
défense a lui même reconnu dans son
briefing quotidien carte à l'appui
une contre-offensive ukrainienne
impossible sans le soutien des
occidentaux et de leurs armes
capable de frapper aussi bien les
premières lignes russes que celle plus
éloignés servant au ravitaillement
le chef de la diplomatie à kiev a
d'ailleurs appelé une nouvelle fois ses
alliés à poursuivre ses livraisons
d'armes alors que petit à petit le
drapeau ukrainien fait son retour sur
les bâtiments officiels comme ici dans
la région de rares kif